[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Denise Howe who is assistant
professor of history at Yale University
she is an historian of modern China with
a particular focus on the social and
cultural history of the MAL period
between 1949 and 1976 she is currently
one of 21 fellows in the public
intellectuals program of the National
Committee on us-china relations today
we'll talk with Professor Howe about her
new book curating revolution politics on
display in Mao's China
welcome professor ho thank you thank you
so much for having me Marilyn let's
start with an overview of your book tell
us about it sure so my book is entitled
curating revolution politics on display
in Mao's China and what I try to do with
the book is to explore the relationship
between politics and exhibitions and
museum culture in the Maui r--'s so how
is it that exhibitions might inspire
people to take part in political
campaigns and the book itself is
structured around six case studies and
they all come from the city of Shanghai
that I think they represent larger
museum culture in China in a much
broader context so let me give you some
examples of the case studies that I'm
sure I have I start and end with two
famous or well-known studies places that
are still still available you could
still visit them in China today the book
starts with a chapter on the first Party
Congress site so this is a revolutionary
history museum it's the place where the
Communist Party was founded in 1921
mmm-hmm
so that starts the book the book ends
with a history of the shanghai museum
which was founded in 1952 and is I think
today probably the most well known most
prestigious Art Museum in China and so
if you've ever been a tourist to
Shanghai
you will probably have gone to the
Shanghai Museum you may or may not have
gone to the first Party Congress site so
those are the famous case studies and
then in between I have a number of
exhibitions that really only exist in
people's memories or in archival
materials so one of them is a history of
a neighborhood to show how the state
made housing for workers a so called
workers new village I have an exhibition
on for children in the 1960s explaining
to them what was super stitch isn't and
what was science juxtaposing those two
behaviors or ways of thinking and then I
have two chapters one of them is about
class education in the years leading up
to the Cultural Revolution and one is on
red guard exhibitions and so between
those examples I have things that are
very well known and things that would
would disappear if we didn't have a
chance to think about them and so with
those examples I really want to bring
people behind the scenes at the museum
not just what was elective visit these
places but how are they put together and
how do they reflect the politics of that
period okay and what led you to be
interested in this that's a good
question I think I was first really
interested in historic preservation
so the preservation of the built
environment of monuments and that
actually goes back to my time as a Yale
undergraduate so almost 20 years ago I
was a sophomore and I took my first
Chinese history class and Jonathan
Spence had a lecture about leung
che-cheung who was he was a Chinese
first architectural historian he studied
at the University of Pennsylvania and in
the early 20th century he and his wife
who was an art historian they went
around China trying to catalog and
preserve ancient buildings in the middle
of wartime and so that was a really
inspiring story for me and I was
interested in historic preservation then
I got to the archive and I discovered
that there's actually a lot of material
about not just buildings temples
historic monuments but about art and
artifacts and so this I think it's
useful here to think about
the Chinese word for cultural relic so
the word is one rule so culture + object
cultural relic and so that includes both
kinds buildings + objects and that
really brought me into the study of
cultural preservation that way and I
ended up writing a dissertation about
Antiquities role in revolution ok and
how did you do the research it must have
been fascinating for you to kind of go
behind the scenes and take a look at
these artifacts and you also did
interviews with people as well - so tell
us about the research so I think the
research proceeded in stages and I like
to talk about this because I think for
graduate students they think it all has
to be complete like a whole book and to
start out with so I started out using
archives mostly the Shanghai Municipal
archive but some district archives as
well and I used the archival materials
to really give background in context to
create the history of the bureaucracy
that took care of culture during the
20th century and how did they define
what was a cultural relic and what
wasn't okay
then in my first job I started to think
of myself more as a cultural historian
and a cultural historian will look at
texts like a movie a book these the that
cultural product becomes a text to read
and so in this way I think I started to
think about the exhibitions as texts and
then finally as you said I got to do a
lot of interviews and do oral history
and that really helped me make the
project come alive to talk to people who
are curators who visited museums and
really put some sense of what it was
like to receive and understand these
exhibitions not just what was the
curators intent okay when you were
talking to some of these people were
there any surprises or things you didn't
expect that came out of those interviews
I think I could come up with a couple of
examples of what was surprising or what
I didn't
expect for some people I didn't expect
how much the cultural revolutions of 66
to 76 this big tumultuous political
event I didn't expect how much it was
taboo for some people and I was it taboo
for example talking asking about what
happened for example someone might say
something like oh it's not really clear
we don't have any records about this
when you having been in the archive I
knew actually there are records so that
is one example
so still to this day people did not want
to speak about that time I think it
really depends on what their role was
and how they feel about it to give you a
different kind of example I interviewed
someone who was a curator of paintings
in the Shanghai Museum and one thing
that surprised me about interviewing her
was how proud she was of the work she
did and the sense of responsibility that
she had to history so I have a chapter
about how people in the museum preserved
objects from destruction and I think I
asked her about things like how did you
feel about revolution and the answers
that I got actually spoke more to her
role as a professional as somebody whose
job as a museum worker was to preserve
these objects for for posterity and so
that was something that was really
interesting that came out of interviews
okay and curating revolution to curate
revolution help us understand what that
actually means so that's the book's
title curating revolution and so what I
try to do my conclusion is to think
beyond what we how we usually think
about curating so we usually think about
curating as just selecting some things
and putting them up when I was working
in the archives I found some interesting
documents around how to make a factory
exhibition in the 1960s and the memo
where the directive was it's not enough
just to put things on display
there's a whole second half and that's
making sure people understand it there's
an educated aspect of it and that they
understand it in the right way okay so
when I think about what it means to
curate revolution I talk about it in
terms of collecting in terms of
narration and then finally in terms of
ritual so collecting is putting together
a collection you don't have you can't
make a display unless you actually have
things to put on display so what is it -
not just collect things that have to do
with the Revolution or things that have
to do with our history but also at the
grassroots things that came from
people's ordinary lives how do you make
a village exhibition how do you make a
school exhibition so collection is just
the first step
narration is also a little more
complicated we think about narration as
the things that are on the walls the
text of the museum we think about the
things that the docent might have said
and we actually have texts what they
said how they were supposed to ask
questions or answer questions but there
are there are a couple of other elements
that don't show up in other studies of
museums one of them is actually going
down and interviewing people who
experienced a historical event and then
using those kind of channeling them or
using them as part of the docent script
and then one other piece that came out
that was really exciting was to have
handwritten notes in the archive from
the docent saying how was it how did
they perform when they were in the
exhibition space so narratives become
really important and then finally I
think the exhibition's in my study
really function as a ritual space mm-hmm
when we think about if we were in New
Haven and we went to the British art
museum or the university art gallery we
think of an individual going by
themselves because they're interested
but in the MAL period it was really
organized you would go with you're
working it it was very formal and you
might be asked to recite slogans at the
beginning or the end of the exhibit you
might be you might hear stories during
the exhibition or you might be called
upon to tell
your own story and then afterward you
would have a meeting in which you would
talk about the proper way to understand
the exhibit so exhibitions in the Maoist
period really become much more of a
ritual space in a way that I think is a
little bit foreign to an American
cultural context definitely in fact you
use the word ritual I would use the word
almost indoctrination in support of Mao
and what was going on politically during
that time correct so I'm curious
most of the exhibits were they
supportive of Mao and what was going on
there was there anything else that kind
of spoke against Mao and what was going
on that did not support the politics of
the day then hmm that's a really good
question this is a very politicized
moment and I think when you said
indoctrination the word that I was
thinking of is propaganda yeah these are
you know absolutely propaganda and or
techniques of propaganda something that
I call my book participatory propaganda
and so it's not just reading a newspaper
or looking at a book these are
interactive spaces and contexts so was
there anything ever against no I didn't
encounter anything against Mao in my
research but I think what's interesting
is you see the behind-the-scenes debates
like how do we present Mao in the early
1920s when the Communist Party was
founded Mao was not that important yet
but the politics of the 1960's said that
you should present Mao as if he were a
central figure so there's a lot of
tension behind the scenes I think that
there were probably some people who
disagreed with the exhibitions and you
don't always get to see those materials
but I did find a report having to do
with the class education exhibition and
it showed up in reports on
counter-revolutionary comments so you
know how at the end of an exhibition
there's often a book where you can leave
comments right and somebody had written
a comment saying your exhibition
very nice but it doesn't it doesn't
manage to cover up some of the
sufferings that the people have faced in
the past few years and in that case he
was talking about famine and then he
wrote about his grandfather starving to
death and the famine and so those kinds
of little critiques you can imagine that
some people had when they went through
the exhibition but for the most part
those kinds of counter narratives aren't
recorded right and I can imagine the
reason for that would but they were
probably even if they had been would
they have been removed I would imagine
just to be supportive of what was going
on during the politics of the day there
so yes that is fascinating so ultimately
what would you like the reader to take
away from your book I have a couple of
conclusions at the end where I think
about how the MAL period is different so
one thing people might ask is how is
this different from before 1949 and and
how is this different from today's China
or how is it different from other
socialist countries how is it different
from the Soviet Union and so in my book
in my conclusion I talked about two
modes of exhibition or a culture one of
them is the mode of the state and power
and the other is the mode of estate and
revolution so the state and power part
is about exhibitions that function as
tools of political legitimacy the
Revolutionary history museum the art
museum the museum about modernization of
architecture housing and I think that
kind of exhibition existed before 49 and
it exists in all kinds of contexts the
exhibitions of the state in power I
think are really an innovation or
something new that comes up during the
MAL period and they actually date from
before 1949 and it exhibitions of State
and Revolution really teach people how
to participate in revolution so to give
an example this phenomenon of new
exhibitions I date back to the land
reform period
when the communist party was still a
guerilla movement it had these base
areas and they would have these very
simple exhibitions in the countryside
where they would just have a table out
and they would put objects on it to show
okay their peasants and landlords here's
a gun this shows that the landlord has
power or they might even invite invite
and this is very performative the
landlord to put on his finest clothes
and put him on display as an example of
his wealth and this is one of the ways
in which categories of class become
legible for ordinary Chinese people
what's a landlord what is a peasant what
is a counter-revolutionary and so one of
the biggest watersheds in 20th century
Chinese history is the Cultural
Revolution where you had people attacked
because of their class background and
made to undergo class struggle and so
one of the things I try to do in my book
is to show how exhibitions before the
Cultural Revolution used personal
possessions to label people as being of
a bad class background this person is a
former capitalist this person still has
capitalist desires and so then people
used those material possessions to label
people as having a bad class and these
have enormous consequences so I think
that's an example of showing how these
exhibits really taught people not just
about a political campaign but how to
take part in it themselves and I think
this is something that we see as a
product of the mail period that is not
often evident in China - anymore and why
do you think that is that's a good
question I so if we think about the
Chinese state today it's a very
confident powerful state that is drawing
on both the revolutionary tradition and
a national tradition I think that the
vast majority of exhibitions in China -
they are the exhibits of the state in
power if you go to Beijing you can go to
the National Museum of China these are
about these are exhibits about political
legitimacy the times when you have the
exhibits of the state and revolution you
have it's when the state goes into a
campaign mode so for example I think the
most classic one might be campaigns
against corrupt officials and in those
cases the techniques that they borrow
here are the here's all of the money
that this person embezzled or whatever
and here's their corrupt lifestyle those
are a throwback to the Mao era so when
the state goes into political campaign
mode I think you have the revival of
that kind of exhibition area culture but
I think for the most part and here's the
main difference the state when those
political campaigns are looking for
enemies the corrupt official for example
these are not enemies of the revolution
they're enemies of the state so I think
that shows how how very different the
Chinese state is today even when it
draws upon that revolutionary repertoire
okay fascinating thank you so much for
being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you for having me for
more information about Professor Howe
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report jled you be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you